matt reeves of batman introduces a brand
new version of the caped crusader to
audiences fleshing out bruce wayne in
ways fans haven't seen in live action
before first the film foregoes the
typical origin story of that fateful
night when thomas and martha wayne
entered crime alley instead it opts to
drop on batman in the second year of his
war on crime in gotham it's the clever
way of giving audiences a young fresh
face take on the character without
retreading too much familiar ground it
seems this narrative decision is working
with audiences and critics alike because
the batman has earned itself a healthy
rating on rotten tomatoes the batman
story also introduces a vicious new
version of the riddler who is much more
of a homegrown terrorist than jim
carrey's mischievous trickster in batman
forever this time around the villain's
motivation centers around exposing and
punishing the corrupt members of
gotham's political and legislative
infrastructure starting with mayor don
mitchell jr riddler murders mitchell in
the film's opening and is this brutal
act that kicks off a sadistic killing
spree that threatens to unleash utter
chaos on gotham with every kill the
riddler ropes batman deeper into a game
of cat and mouse that gets way more
personal than bruce wayne could have
imagined the riddler puts the wayne
family in his crosshairs because he
believes thomas and martha wayne had as
much responsibility for gotham's
downfall as mayor mitchell the mobster
carmine falcone and other high-profile
gotham figures with shady backgrounds
the masked killer goes deep into the
truth about the wanes in a tell-all
video revealing many dark secrets about
bruce's parents
including their connection to the arkham
family so how are the wanes tied to the
arkhams in the batman we learned thomas
wayne married martha arkham yes that's
right martha is part of the arkham
family it's a surprise for fans to be
sure previous live-action batman movies
have never looked at the history of the
waynes including those who married into
the family in great detail there's a
throwaway line in christopher nolan's
trilogy about one of bruce wayne's
ancestors building an underground
railroad to help slaves escape which
helps explain the existence of the caves
underneath wayne manor but aside from
that we don't know much about the wayne
family tree until now in the batman the
dark knights investigation leads him to
the abandoned orphanage that was
originally supported by the wayne
foundation before the untimely deaths of
thomas and martha he's led to the
rundown location after it is mentioned
in a shocking video released by the
riddler that shines a light on the wanes
in great detail the villain explains
that martha was born into the arkham
family in her youth martha dealt with
mental illness and per riddler had
several stays in the arkham asylum to
treat her the riddler's video on the
wanes also reveals that edward elliot a
journalist employed by style moroni
found out about martha's past and
threatened to expose the news to derail
thomas's mayoral campaign bruce's father
leans on carmine falcone for support
asking the gangster to intimidate the
journalists so the story can stay in the
wraps
this is why riddler targets the wayne
legacy it looks like thomas had eliot
killed anyone even remotely familiar
with the batman mythos will probably
recognize the name arkham thanks to the
notoriety of arkham asylum typically
it's arkham asylum where the caped
crusader sends his opponents after
beating them black and blue in the
streets tying batman directly to arkham
through his mother's bloodline is an
interesting way of making this new
universe feel interconnected rather than
playing with random chess pieces there's
also some extensive history to the
asylum in the comics the location was
first introduced in 1974's batman issue
258 and was known as the elizabeth
arkham asylum for the criminally insane
grant morrison's arkham asylum a serious
house on serious earth establishes that
the iconic location was originally
founded by amadeus arkham in the early
1900s after his mother died by suicide
he transforms the family home into an
institution before his wife and daughter
were killed by his first patient martin
hawkins this eventually drove amadeus
mad and he was locked up in his own
asylum but when it comes to bruce's
mother her maiden name is martha kane in
the comics
it wasn't until jeff john's batman earth
1 that dc introduced her arkham heritage
she also suffers from mental illness in
the 2012 series and there's also the
idea that arca mana is cursed
supposedly dooming any future generation
to eventual mental illness
if you or someone you know is struggling
with mental health please contact the
crisis text line by texting home to 741
741 or call the national alliance on
mental illness helpline at
1-800-950-6264
or visit the national institute of
mental health website